but no there's like all these boys all
throughout the movie who are just
shirtless for no reason they're making
gay jokes and stuff I'm like this is
weird this is the second on the second
one
they're not directed by the same person
they are they're both written and
directed by the same person but the
first one doesn't have gay undertones
well doesn't really only just two
characters basically the second ones
like a bus full of schoolboys
so did this horror movie rut as we will
now furthermore refer to as did this
spawn from insidious yes okay well I saw
a new another trailer the same trailer
you know for the millionth time of don't
be afraid of the dark so you going
forward to that'll be good yeah that
looks awesome
um I don't like that trailer but the
movies probably gonna be really good
because it's like you know the ELMO guy
Pearce's in it you know Larimer I
thought it was Mark Wahlberg no that's a
guy Paris Commune Katie Holmes she's in
a movie all of a sudden I was Mark
Wahlberg and Katie Holmes nope what the
haha
IMDB that crap yes I can of course I can
hear you're typing it's like this being
pounded into my brain says guy here I'm
so convinced it's Mark Wahlberg sorry
well that's pretty stupid of you telling
y'all was gonna be in this movie
yes I just I don't know please come Wow
no but um insidious and then like
screening for and Jeepers Creepers to
and all these movies and I just I want
to see the crazies oh that's pretty cool
yeah it's kind of its kind of them a
better action movie than it is a horror
movie but it's a good movie
nonetheless I love Tim
he's good in that movie I really enjoyed
that movie I watched it right after
having surgery yeah yeah oh well there
was this one time recently see I'm
getting over a cold and like the last
weekend - nothing but watch movies I
watched all four diehards that was fun
we the most overrated action movie of
all time
f I I said f EF f ya what does that
stand for
it stands for your dumb diehards amazing
what's your host on yeah it is yeah you
know what okay let's also you know it's
also amazing the five billion movies
that are exactly like it oh but they all
spawned from it diehard inspired quite a
lot of them are better than it it
alright let's have a legit debate why
don't you like tired that much I don't
dislike it it's just there's nothing
special about it
I disagree okay
John McTiernan is direction for that
everybody is amazing disagree regarding
this direction I you know I'm frankly
found it to be mundane and oldish I
don't even know what that word it means
Ellen freakin Rickman gave a fantastic
performance oh really
I thought he was better in Harry Potter
but he's such a good villain yeah he's a
villain every part of genius you would
know this if you've watched the Harry
Potter movies yeah get rid of your first
folks
Chris Duckman does not watch Harry
Potter you wanted a miracle I give you
the FB okay come on Bruce Willis man the
die hard man I'm stuffing Harry Potter
now that we've brought it up I'm sorry
yeah ironically it's Emma Watson's
birthday today happy 21st babe go get
drunk
don't do that so don't stay young and
fresh I just want to know why she's a
dyke haircut it's called a pixie or
whatever pixie cut it's called looking
like a lesbian maybe she's a lesbian
I don't think so would that make her
more attractive to you
something tells me all the comments in
the under section are gonna be a whole
sizeable debate now okay they're gonna
donate about my Harry Potter and then
gays is not a style do you like any
other dang guards um I haven't seen the
third but I liked the second and I liked
the board a lot to be honest I saw you
know I saw them and I was blown away by
how much I loved the third one Oh
the third I haven't seen the third but I
saw the fourth one right when it came
out before I max for I actually saw the
others and I really really really really
liked it my least favorite is - I like -
I know you're weird you do not like one
but you like I do not dislike one I just
prefer the other ones that I've seen -
is like literally widely known as the
worst as the worst I liked about in the
first one see that's weird
on IMDb thigh heart has like an eight
point eight out of ten and I aren't you
I was like a seven out of ten and then I
live above the influence three you're
under the influence it was a good movie
taste No oh and and three has like a
seven point five and four is also a
seven point five my obsessive-compulsive
memory actually remembers that no you're
right our lemma freak freak how long has
it been since you've watched iron I'm
seriously going to like convert
elephants in my house huh
are you gonna like mail a copy to my
house no I'm gonna convert you to
Judaism Ted diehard ISM yeah I'll pass
I'd rather be a Mormon
Bruce Willis is amazing okay uh all
right uh uh I don't really want to watch
it again this is the same thing they
have with predator I told you that I did
it like I didn't that's right you know I
told you that I hadn't seen predator you
went crazy
thank you I saw I saw it I told you that
I just thought it was okay and then you
crapped yourself it's because obviously
you don't understand
good action direction oh yes clearly um
how do you not think predator and die
hard this will be a thousand comments
saying you're kidding you know it's
gonna happen I want to ignore I wanted
to avoid that but you're like really
wanting it to happen
that's something it's like no we're
gonna stay on predator you're not die
hard something about popular science
fiction movies like I think like every
popular science fiction movie is
overrated Star Wars - 2001 Blade Runner
alien predator like they're all it's
overrated I agree with you about 2001
and later they're okay but alien is not
good it's just my imprisoners boring
predator I don't find boring I do you
think alien is good
do you like aliens I'm a senior I'm
actually seeing that in theaters
tomorrow believe it or not that's like I
write it okay I should have said alien
is not good I was just expecting a lot
more and because of that I did not you
know go and watch the second one but I
want to see it eventually actually
that's fine James Cameron there's other
science fiction movies that take over if
I can't think about let me look at my
DVDs something about science fiction the
matrix an hour necessarily so overrated
I don't think love it I
I love the matrix in the Star Wars
anyway
avatar
we've talked about this I think everyone
on the planet yeah I was just about to
say that everyone thinks avatars are
routed the only reason is because it
made seven hundred gazillion dollars or
whatever it
let's see cuz I mean it's a really good
movie but there are better movies out
there and I think it's basically because
the 3d they made it makes so much money
well yeah uh everyone saw it in 3d
because 3d wasn't so overused about the
Jurassic Park I haven't seen it recently
enough to say it's amazing inception
inception no you know that's not true
thank goodness The Terminator
yes yes the turn and that's that's the
one I couldn't remember the first two
terminators are so overrated first the
first one sucks why not dad reading the
first one is crap
the second one is pretty good oh my god
is amazing the first one is boring
no the first one is so predictable so
dull
the finale is retarded I was just
absolutely chasing her for 45 freakin
minutes I like the second one a lot I do
think it's a little Morita so many
people think it's the greatest science
fiction football time but I do not like
the first one at all I don't like the
third one either but I like where many
people do so it's like an Matrix
Reloaded well thank you for finding the
movie I was thinking of that we can quit
this whole science fiction thing now so
I found it I'm content is Danny wanna
quit cuz I'm just naming off all these
incredibly awesome
like that sucks I know what I'm talking
about I'm a pretentious prick yeah
that's not true I know you know that I
dislike people like that I am not doing
it on purpose I just like how I am
superior I understand you just like
yourself currently I do not dislike
myself alright folks on this short
period of time we've discovered that
Blake isn't really a huge fan of
Terminator duck hard predator what else
alien does no one believe let's just say
it down it's not science picture but I
just like Goodfellas god bless me yeah
well you know what first time I saw it I
didn't really like it
I won't we see it at once I don't want
to see it again yeah I really see no
effects well I'm afraid that if I want
you to get up like go into a coma I'm
afraid I'll watch it again and like it
and I'll be like it's okay I don't like
this I don't like Citizen Kane or The
Godfather though you know you haven't
seen Citizen Kane well that's right I've
seen the first hour my dad you could old
movies could really work as a whole
you've not seen this is that is true but
like you have not seen Citizen Kane I
know all I'm saying is that generally
have more than likely I still won't like
it
hey Chris yes you haven't seen Citizen
Kane I agree it's that part of the
podcast ladies and gentlemen yes it's
the part where Blake craps and throws it
against the wall I got a few new DVDs
wanna know what they are no so you can
tell me they're overrated
no won't see bad I got avatar believing
what's the three-disc yeah though this
Petrus traffic a group yeah I got like I
said I got all four diehards I got let's
see oh I got Independence Day I love
that movie I haven't seen it
Rose I have SIF I had seen it I promise
it's overrated you haven't the
independence thing
Subaru what are you gonna tell me next
you haven't seen no-name a movie because
I might not have seen it it'd be funny
about seeing star wars with Star Wars
yes I thought I got Jeepers Creepers
which I loved the first one oh yeah
I got Michael Jackson's vision it's a
set containing every single Michael
Jackson music video
oh so that's what they're called yeah
are you sure it's not just like to our
footage of Macaulay Culkin as a little
kid oh my gosh that is one thing you
don't joke with me about whoopsies
MJ anyway I also Bobby I've ever seen
the Patriot Mel Gibson is the first
r-rated movie I ever saw that's for me I
bought it
there's like five bucks hey did you know
that did you know that they're making a
patriot - no yeah Keith ledger will be
reprising his role as the dead son yes
ladies and gentlemen I just went in
forbidden territory slight slightly like
my boss told me the other day not
because you've seen the Sandlot dude I
saw this a lot when I was like three
oh god forbid are you being serious are
you kidding you like dude thus a lot
like formed every the childhood of like
every male in America
I seriously don't know like a single it
that I have not seen at one point quote
the Sandlot I know it it's hilarious
because like you know inside
DVD every kid was like actually on VHS
every kid is like mom this movie's
amazing can we watch it a thousand times
and I played baseball like up until this
couple years ago I quit like every team
would always quote the Sandlot non-stop
do you seriously think it's overrated of
course not I love the same one okay